عدد من الفلسطينيين فجر اليوم بحالات
اختناق بالغاز المسيل للدموع والرصاص
المعدني المغلفه بالمطاط خلال مواجهات مع
قوات الاحتلال في قريه كفر نعمه غربيه
مدينه رام الله كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
في حي خلت العمود في مدينه نابلس
واعتقلت السيره المحرر معتصم ان بولسي
وقالت مجموعه عرين الاسود انها اشتبكت مع
قوات الاحتلال بالرصاص والقنابل المحليه
الصنع خلال انسحابها من المدينه
على الاقل بينهم سيدتان خلال حمله مداهمات
للمناطق الفلسطينيه بالضفه الغربيه وافادت
مؤسسات الاسرى ان قوات الاحتلال اعتقلت
سبعه فلسطينيين من مخيم الدهيشه للاجئين
قضاء بيت لحم بينهم سيده
رجاء ذلك بعد اقتحام قوات الاحتلال
المخيمه وسط مواجهات مع الشبان ما ادى الى
اصابه شاب على الاقل برصاص الاحتلال في
منطقه الصدر وقد نقل الى المستشفى
انضموا الينا من رام الله مراسلنا سميره
اذا تطورات عديده في مدن في الضفه الغربيه
من اقتحامات ومواجهات ما الذي يجري
نعم هذا ما يعرف بحمله كاسر الامواج التي
بدات منذ اكثر من عام في الضفه الغربيه
والقدس المحتله والتي تهدف من خلال قوات
الاحتلال الاعتقال المطلوبين لديها في
المناطق الفلسطينيه قوات الاحتلال فجاه في
الليله الماضيه
اقتحمت حله العمود في داخل مدينه نابلس من
عده محاور ودهمت احد المنازل في ذلك الحي
واعتقلت الاسير المحرر المعتصم النابلسي
وهو ابن عم الشهيد ابراهيم النابلسي احد
مؤسسي وقيادات مجموعات عرين الاسود
المشكله من مسلحين في داخل مدينه نابلس
قبل ذلك كان هناك ايضا اشتباكات تخلل هذه
العمليه وعمليه الاقتحام الاشتباكات مع
مقاتلين مجموعات عرين الاسود التي اكدت في
بيان عسكري مقتضب لها بانها هي اشتبكت مع
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالرصاص الحي
وايضا
القنابل محليه الصنع خلال العمليه
وانسحابها من المدينه كان هناك قبل ذلك
بقليل كان هناك اقتحام لبلده او قريه
عينبوس وهي الواقعه في جنوب مدينه نابلس
واعتقال الشيخ كايد حمد من هذه القريه
تزامن ذلك كلهما اقتحامات اخرى في مناطق
متعدده في الضفه الغربيه اسفرت عن اعتقال
14 فلسطينيا الليله الماضيه وايضا فجر هذا
اليوم ايضا كان هناك اقتحام لقريه بيت
لقيا وايضا قريه كفر نعمه في غربيه وجنوب
غربيه مدينه رام الله وكذا هناك اعتقالات
لعدد من الشبان الفلسطينيين في بيت لقيا
كان هناك اعتقال لشابين احدهما الصحفي
محمد بدر وهو اسير محرر ايضا وفي كفر نعمه
تم اعتقال شاب في هذه القريه وتخلل ذلك
ايضا مواجهات مع قوات الاحتلال اسفلت عن
اصابه ثلاثه فلسطينيين وص احدهم بالخطيره
حيث كان هناك اصابه للاثنين اخرين
الاقدام خلال هذه المواجهات التي اندلعت
في القريه ايضا كان هناك اقتحام في صباح
هذا اليوم لمخيم الدهيشن للاجئين في مدينه
بيت لحم حيث تم اعتقال سبعه فلسطينيين على
الاقل بينهم سيده وايضا هذه هذا الاقتحام
وهذه العمليه العسكريه ايضا تضمنتها
عمليات مواجهات عنيفه مع شبان المخيم
اسفلت عن اصابه ثلاثه فلسطينيين اصابه
احدهم بالخطيره حيث اصيب في منطقه الصدر
وحسب المصادر الطبيه الفلسطينيه وفي مخيم
شعفاط شرقي مدينه القدس المحتله كان هناك
احتجاز واعتقال لسيده وتم نقل جميع
المعتقلين الى مراكز التوقيف للتحقيق معهم
في ملفات تتعلق بمقاومه الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه
من رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك